you the best for last
so it's my pleasure to introduce
she's an associate professor of
operations research at Yale and she's an
expert on matching markets platform
design and she's looked at a variety of
different kinds of applications in her
work and today she'll tell us about
volunteer match
that's another one hey thank you for
sticking around for the very last Talk
of the workshop really appreciate it and
today I'm gonna share with you joint
work with three great quarters Scott
rodelits Daniela sabon and actually your
search but before I'll tell you about
our world I want to start by making a
broader point
many of us participating in this program
work on uh online platforms and that
usually means commercial platforms think
Uber Airbnb up work and so on and that's
great these platforms have given us a
lot of good problems to study
well I want to highlight that similarly
in the world of non-profits we have a
lot of good platforms as well
here I'm just showing you a few uh a few
of my favorites they have many many more
and I want to say that I think this is a
good opportunity for us too by studying
these types of platforms we can find
interesting kind of abstract research
problems related to a data-driven
decision processes the theme of this
entire program and not only that if you
take a research idea to practice
we may be able to make a positive social
impact
the theme of this for
instruction now my plan in today's talk
is to tell you about our work in
collaboration with one of these
organizations which is volunteer match
to hopefully illustrate uh both of these
two parties
let me tell you a little bit of
background about volunteer imagine then
I'll jump right into our research
question
which is an online matching platform
very much like upwork but in instead of
helping you find the temp job is going
to help you find a volunteering
opportunity
it's the largest largest of such
platforms that we have in the in the
nation with about 1.3 million monthly
visitors
over a hundred thousands opportunities
on a variety of causes ranging from
Hunger to education to human rights
it's a great platforms it does a great
service to society but the challenge is
that currently lots of opportunities on
this uh platform do not address do not
receive as many volunteer sign ups as
they would like to
did I start this point
let me show you one sample of sign up
distributions
so this is a distribution of sign ups
for a hundred randomly selected
opportunities that all asks for five
seconds
now
if you look at the left side we see that
there are lots of opportunities that do
not receive five signups
so of course that's not great but if you
look at the left at the right side you
see that we do have opportunities that
receive many more than they asked so
they ask for five they get 30 they get
40.
great either
why
this congestion in kind of Market design
language right
usually volunteering requires some kind
of screening process by spending so many
uh volunteers interested volunteers to
its organizations we are going to
overburden them
and that's right at some point they're
gonna stop responding to these
volunteers
in turn those volunteers are going to be
disappointed that they may get
disengaged from the platform all
together
so so far we see that uh this kind of
students are in our distribution is bad
for these opportunities but for these
opportunities and bad for volunteers and
of course it's bad for volunteer match
because Valencia match doesn't make as
many uh connections as it could have
potentially made
because our research agenda is going to
revolve around the following question
we designed VMS platform to maximize the
number of useful science exams
okay
so that's kind of our high level
research questions
answer this question
I had to understand the sources of
inefficiencies what leads to this kind
of skew distributions
and one factor that we found which is
within the control of the platform is
the effect of the recommendation
algorithm or the ranking algorithm that
the platform is
roughly speaking
the platform uses a ranking algorithm
that is kind of recency based so it
shows opportunities that have been
updated or newer on top of the list
naturally they get more attention
and they get more side and in some sense
VM ignores the kind of higher number of
sign ups at a particular opportunity has
turns out there are some organizations
out there that update their
opportunities very frequently as a
result of this they end up on the top of
the list
uh quite often and they get so many
exercises
so by based on this observation we
thought that okay
all you need to do is add some kind of a
feedback loop to take into account the
current number of signups and if you do
that maybe you are able to shift some of
these excess signups to the left side of
this distribution
right
that seems reasonable
deeper to this uh data it's not a
slightly different picture
so this is what we saw
same distribution I'm just color coding
sign ups based on their sources
it turns out that on VM there are two
sources of signups internal and extract
let me first tell you what's an external
signup
signups that are generated by users that
have direct link to a particular
opportunity okay so somehow I have a
link to a particular opportunity page I
just go directly to that page so I will
never interact with the recommendation
algorithm
so in some sense these are uh sign ups
from users that cannot be influenced
we also have this internal traffic these
are the default users right so the ones
that go on volunteer match and
organically look for an opportunity so
they interact with this without
recognition
but so again based on this uh digging
deeper into the data we observe this
prevalence of external traffic
let me tell you where external traffic
comes from
from kind of off-platform Outreach
activities
so it turns out organizations use
volunteer match for multiple purposes
one of them is of course to attract
volunteers
but they also use VM for uh showcasing
their products managing relationship
with volunteers and so on and because of
these other purposes even when they
attract traffic externally they still
give the link to the dedicated page on
quality imagine
so let me show you one quick example
here's an organization that publicizes
its opportunity on LinkedIn but it still
gives the link to this page on bullets
okay so bottom line if I click on this
I'm never gonna interact with your
recommendation algorithm
no matter how good of an algorithm you
design you're not going to influence my
decision
right
surprisingly about 30 percent of track
click on volunteer match is actually
external
so substantial amount and as you just
saw in the previous histogram in the
previous Slide the amount of external
traffic varies quite a bit across
different opportunities so it's not
uniformly distributed and also it's of
course uncertain and unknown
yes
um so when you say it's unknown at what
stage do they know it like is there any
stage before the volunteer activity
itself no no not necessarily right so it
can arrive anytime
before before the
for the event and also lots of these
opportunities are not that time
sensitive in the sense that they're
ongoing for a long time
but good question
so feel free to ask any question also uh
following I Read's great initiative
any question
let me just follow up to clarify on that
um so this link this
like when they click in that's this is
still hosted by volunteer match but they
were not linking within volunteer match
like sign ups or to recommendation right
it's just like I go here and I sign up
for this or not but I'm not going to ask
you that hey can you show me a list of
possibilities among which I'm gonna make
a selection right so I've decided I want
to do this one potentially right
great question
all right good so based on this
observation we are going to yes
see they see the recommend that they see
the ranking they just decide to Launch
so you're saying do you see the ranking
but they just decide to you know go to
the website directly no the thing is
that I am on LinkedIn yeah for whatever
reason I see this
right I click on this go directly to
this National First Responders fund page
and I never go to the main page of
Valencia match right
but good question
cool yes Daniel
a bit outside of the controls that
you're considering in your talk but
wouldn't an option be to if somebody
goes directly to the opportunity and the
opportunity is already full
basically push them to
hear other opportunities that are
similar that you might be interested in
awesome is that happening and if yes
um the
yeah for certain opportunities they come
from an organization that also has a
bunch of other opportunities and usually
on the kind of bottom of the page they
show those other things that okay but
that's a good question
I'm not considering that in my model but
cool so okay let me just quickly refine
my research question
based on our observation our refined
research question is now how to make
much recommendations that are useful to
increase the number of useful signups in
the presence of such external objects
now before telling you what you did with
this question let me tell you that
external traffic is not limited to
volunteer much
some online matching platforms play do
all roles they facilitate connection but
they also facilitate transactions and
because of this second role they attract
external traffic from many different
chats
let me show you two quick examples
one from the world of retail
on Etsy artists sell their products
their handmade products but they usually
advertise those products in social media
say on Instagram
as you can see even within Instagram
that they advertise it they give the
link to the page on Etsy for their
product
back to the world of nonprofits donors
choose is a great crowdfunding platform
that helps high school teachers solicit
donations for high school projects and
again these teachers not only rely on
donors choose to attract donations they
also advertise on other websites
traffic appears in a variety of
applications
which motivates our research and for
this question let me quickly summarize
our contributions
when you make two types of contributions
one is theoretical one is applied
on the theoretical side uh we introduce
a generalization of online matching
which is online matching with
multi-china traffic and for this problem
we design a new algorithm that
effectively uh takes advantage of this
the external nature of this traffic
and like by doing that it does better
than the existing algorithms
in the paper we showed that this our
algorithm not only has a good kind of
theoretical guarantees but when we apply
it on in a case to 32 VM data it does it
does pretty well in in practice too
um yes so they think of the external
traffic as predictable or is it uh very
much non-stationary no it can be
arbitrary as I will specify in the model
section okay yes there's a question in
the back I can also repeat the question
so do you consider like preferences of
users for certain uh places or like rank
organizations based on like their impact
or something right so that those are
going to be reflected in their kind of
Click probabilities right so if I show
you different things that you have
different preferences for we're gonna
click on them with different properties
good so that's on the theoretical
foreign paper on the applied side we
proposed a new recommendation algorithm
to volunteer match which is inspired by
our Theory uh after of course taking
into account certain practical
considerations and limitations
we've worked with Valencia match to
implement smart sorts that's the name of
our algorithm
on their platform and we already
conducted the field experiments in
Dallas
so and I'm going to show you the results
which is the first time that is being
protected by the way okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start with this uh it's our theoretical
paper toward the end I show you the
results of our files
but before I start any any other
question
okay great so let me introduce the model
just like a very again simple
generalization of online matching so I
have this bipartite graph one side is
offline which for me would be these
opportunities
each opportunity has a capacity which
reflects the number of volunteers it
needs
now on the online science volunteers are
going to arrive uh one by one
of course the innovation of our work is
that volunteers can be two different
types
either they are external in which they
have a dedicated opportunity we are not
going to make any decision for them so
think of them as a degree one not in
your online bipartite matching problem
but the degree one note that you have to
assign so you cannot drop
okay so again no decision to be made
here life is easy but for internal
traffic once they arrive You observe
their compatibility patterns and out of
all the compatible opportunities we're
going to recommend one uh on the Fly
if you comment this one
and of course our goal is to
design algorithms that maximize the size
of this matching without making any
assumption about the traffic pattern
so
so as the volunteer match why should I
care about the matching of the external
traffic in my objectives
so you count like the number of external
traffic
this organization right
count them it's fine
it's fine I as long as they all match
you don't it doesn't matter which which
version you look at just to keep things
simple we keep all of them but doesn't
matter if you don't
as long as you don't drop it okay
yes
of course
is there a distinction between
volunteers or is there any it doesn't
matter whether which volunteer excellent
excellent
volunteers
each volunteer has it
if you follow up on that by saying that
I am presenting this in the simplest
possible form so I have zero one
compatibility and I'm making a single
opportunity recommendation in the paper
and as I show you a little bit later we
we do look at generalizations in which
you have probabilistic compatibilities
like conversion probabilities and also I
can offer you a subset not just one
foreign
I have uh these two types of volunteers
external ones I don't need to do
anything internal ones I'm going to make
one match recommendation uh among the
compatible ones with the goal of
maximizing the size of my magic
now say I designed an algorithm how
would I know if it's good
of course we're going to take the
standard approach of competitive
analysis
now most of you know how this works but
let me just spend a moment and explain
what a competitive ratio analysis
if
so what we do here is that you give me
an algorithm for that algorithm I'm
going to compare its performance of this
online algorithm that doesn't know
anything about future arrivals with that
of a clairvoyant solution that sees the
entire sequence before making any
decision so I compute this ratio I take
the worst case overall problem instances
to get the competitive ratio of a
particular algorithm
all right
good now for a second if I ignore
external traffic altogether
okay those of you work in this area you
know that this is a very well studied
problem
we know pretty much all we want to know
about this problem thanks to a very nice
paper about 15 years ago by methos
it's a really nice paper and I'm not
just saying this because one of the
authors was my advisor but it was
actually pretty nice and it wasn't
influential paper it did influence
practice
okay what does this paper show it shows
that
the best competitive ratio you can get
is one minus one over e and not only
that when capacities are large they they
gave an algorithm that gives us a
matching level basically achieved
achieves one minus one
good so again this is for the case that
they have no external traffic
the extra The Other Extreme in which all
my traffic is external
just to make sure who is a vacant who is
not
definition would I get if all my
[Laughter]
I'm gonna get one and the catch here is
that uh this external traffic but the
virtue of being inflexible is going to
limit the number of mistakes that an
online algorithm can make compared to an
offline
so it limits the power of adverse sites
now based on this I'm going to refine my
notion of competitive ratio by
parameterizing it based on a parameter
better
this parameter better tells us what
fraction of entire capacity we can fill
using external traffic
now once you fix better I'm gonna be
looking for a worst case ratio across
all instances that have this much except
traffic
correct so again my question is that how
much how helpful this external traffic
is or what is the best we can get for
different values of beta
so
in order to answer this question I'm
going to first start with the warm-up
case you have questions
good excellent
in theory yes
for the algorithm we have I'll show you
so just don't spoil my my algorithm okay
just wait for it but no okay I already
disappointed okay okay so warm-up case
let's look at this super unrealistic
setting in which all my external traffic
arrives before the internal once
let's think about it for a second for
the first bit of fraction that are
external I'm making no mistakes my
competitive ratio is one for the rest of
it it's a typical online matching
problem
thanks to the nice paper by my advisor
and his co-authors and his advisor
actually we know that the chance to do
better than one minus one over eight
so if you think about it just second
it's natural that the upper bound is
going to be simply the convex
combination of these two extreme points
so start from one minus one over even
you have no external traffic goes all
the way to one when all your traffic is
but if you apply msdv just naively
it turns out that you cannot get a
matching lure
okay so the paper will show that the
mscv cannot do better than this red
curve
but if you adjust them as stupid just a
little bit to get a new algorithm that
we call adaptive capacity you can get
back a matching robot
so the idea behind that algorithm is
very simple and Supernatural for this
special case
because I told you again in this in this
uh warm-up case the first bit of
fraction are external so I'm gonna let
them arrive and fill capacities and then
once I'm done with that bit of fraction
I'm just going to adjust my capacities
this is reduce my capacities
and that I have a new problem instance
run MSC
I have no idea
which gives us this matching lower belt
is that of course in a general case
external traffic arrows throughout so I
don't know how much I should reduce my
capacity a priority what am I gonna do
I'm going to do it on the fly so as I
get external traffic I'm going to reduce
and that's the whole idea of that
let me formalize this for you
here's our algorithm we have two
counters for each opportunity one for
external one for internal for external
ones we don't do anything if we get an
external traffic we do nothing if we get
an internal one then we are gonna match
this internal traffic to a compatible
opportunity that maximizes this penalty
function
and later this penalty function is that
they're going to penalize opportunities
that have already got a bunch of signups
so it is a decreasing function in both
of our counters but the whole kind of
catch is that we are going to treat
these two counters differently and in
particular we are going to subtract the
counter for external traffic from our
capacity
yes question
foreign
your algorithm for every external one
all I need to do is to increase this
counter right so I whenever I get an
external traffic I just increase the
counter by one right
maybe I'll follow up on that
yeah
um so in in the actual application do
you get this external traffic
information as it's coming in or is it
kind of batched
um yeah how frequently are you seeing
good good good that depends very much on
like this uh your the sophistication of
the technology that you use currently no
it's more like kind of a daily based
daily level okay but it get into all of
this and kind of things more apart
a few comments
as I already told the tutorials
in designing this algorithm I never use
beta so my algorithm is better agnostic
which is great because it's it's kind of
not feasible to know better up front in
practice
second this is a deterministic algorithm
of course which is usually in practice
when you're dealing with practitioners a
deterministic algorithm is more
desirable compared to randomized
and the first one I want to make is that
I want to draw a quick comparison with
msvb
it does something very similar to what
we do it maximizes a potential function
in case you haven't seen this algorithm
before the only difference is that it
treats the two uh sources of traffic
symmetric
now what what do we get for this
algorithm or in general case
okay yes
I I think you wanted to uh teach us the
simple version right and you drop the
vertex face but if you drop the vertex
face you don't need to I don't need them
and generally that once you bring the
weights then you would need that
expansion and here's my actual question
so my actual question is uh if you run
mscv how would it be different from this
nspd penalizes external traffic larger
if you compare the two fractions for
mstv is always larger than the other one
the penalty is the stronger Pharmacy
and with that
I see Basics so the fraction the kind of
you would think that you feel more than
more of your capacity
but great question
cool so this is a summary of the couple
of important theorems in the paper
we show that in this General case
um no algorithm deterministic or
randomized can do better than this solid
Blue Line
you care I should say it starts from one
minus one over e again it stays at one
minus one already all the way to uh then
you have better equal 1 over e and then
it goes off it it increases with better
all the way to one when you have a
fully external chart
okay
so that's our upper bound the kind of
more important results is the lower
boundary proof for adaptive capacity
under the large capacity assumption
so our lower bound is
a distorted uh blue curve okay so it's
close and the conjecture that if it
tighten just one part of the analysis is
going to be matching but for now the
best we can show is this dotted
yes
so if you looked at the comparative
ratio just over the internal traffic if
uh well if all the external traffic
comes first then you're just doing msvv
on the remaining capacities and you
match the one minus one over e if the
traffic is in interspersed how bad can
it get do you have any like can can you
achieve any finite competitive Ratio or
so it's like I am taking out the
constant from my numerator and
denominator right so like this is the
algebraically work that out
yeah so you you could construct some
example where it goes to zero right
okay so again for it for adaptive
capacity to prove this lower bound uh
this dotted curve and of course I'll
also we show that for mspp we cannot do
better than this uh
one in line
um wait
making this simple adjustment based on
the source of the traffic we get a near
optimal algorithm for any value of
better without actually needing to know
the values
good so let me spend just a moment maybe
30 seconds on the proof the proof relies
on this relatively recent framework
that's called the lp free framework for
analysis of online algorithms developed
by Rajan odwani who is actually UC
Berkeley and his co-authors so this is
like Builds on the prime module analysis
which is the standard method it's just a
slightly more flexible which is useful
for us because we want to Define
different kind of do all variables or
rewards for internal life Etc
not getting into any details instead
let me quickly talk about extensions and
then move on to the applied
so as I promised in the paper we relax
the assumption that compatibility
compatibility structure is zero one and
also we are showing only a single uh
single recommendation
we look at the stochastic reward in
which we have a conversion probability
for every pair of volunteer and
opportunities and also we look at
situations in which we offer a subset or
a
A ranked list of opportunities to
internal traffic and all of this
adaptive capacity or its natural
generalization that suits that
particular model still does well and in
many cases it breaks the this one minus
mono very barriers
yes
so when you rece you saw more than one
what is the Assumption about how the
volunteer is maybe they go to both of
them or are they good so we have
different Choice models so we look at
kind of a general uh choice choice model
uh for the subset selection for like
assortment planning for ranking we have
a different we have a we look at
different models for how I would search
when you show me like a vertically
differentiated piece
cool
so with that let me quickly summarize
the theory part and then show you some
experimentalists
so if your theory paper we were
motivated by the design of online
platforms that play dual roles of
facilitating connection and transactions
and because of this they attract traffic
from different chats
so be sure that uh by taking into
account the fact that they have this
external traffic and designing our
algorithms tailoring an algorithm and
algorithms to that uh we can get uh near
Optimal Performance
uh and the nice thing about that
algorithm which makes it practical also
is that it doesn't need to know external
traffic
I like that uh
Beyond kind of our modeling contribution
on a kind of more abstract uh level we
contribute to this stream of literature
that tries to break away from fully
adversarial models that can sometimes be
pessimistic how do they do that they try
to come up with a more realistic and uh
motivated well motivated traffic models
I think it's a great area of research
and perhaps we need more papers in this
area
but future research I think there is a
lot to be done on the theory side my
favorite is that what if we can design
at least part of the external traffic
and it's actually motivated by what we
learned about VA it turns out that
volunteer match itself is active on
social media and they sent out a bunch
of daily emails promoting certain
opportunities so effectively they also
generate external traffic
but external traffic that is within
their control so in some sense you can
think about designing at this part of
Etc
good and also you can think about
looking at different objective options
here we just look at look at maximizing
the size of the match
with that I want to switch gears to talk
about the
applied part but before doing that any
more questions
so do you have any thoughts on the
version of the problem where the
external traffic or degree two nodes
because
the Greet through note meaning that I
will how would I choose between the
internet is in your hand
it's in your control so you can do can
do whatever you want
great so
because one way of looking a little bit
better right so your bounds are all
gonna kind of be dominating the ones
that they have right I think there is a
paper that looks at the situation in
which
that one is I think as soon as all the
traffic is exactly all the way or up to
d right it doesn't necessarily need to
be uh
uh yeah I don't have any kind of like
expression or analytical results to show
you but uh intuitively you would do
slightly better than what we do yeah I
think you want to kind of do this idea
of decreasing capacity yeah yeah I was
curious like what's the trade-off I mean
or what's the right dependency on beta
and D at the same time yeah yeah that's
that's a very good question I think
that's an excellent research question
well I guess a related question is uh
there's also like a I think from the
same paper by like bjn07 like there's
results on like if you know for if
you're guaranteed for each offline
vertex a certain fraction that's going
to be matched by the end you can get
certain guarantees so it's a bit similar
in that like you instead of external
traffic you're just told at the
beginning like the fractions that you're
able to match by the end for the offline
like is your model like does the having
the external traffic and said is it like
harder or easier than that model is your
competitive ratio Better or Worse good
good I think that is not super
compatible because that's going to be a
very loose bound like you get some lower
bound or based on external traffic but
that that can be very off right compared
to uh papers
okay okay but the external traffic
essentially guarantees you that you're
gonna match to like the uh I see but the
external traffic you don't know which
offline vertex is going to be for
awesome awesome great so another
important Point here is that beta only
gives me a fraction over all things and
in fact if I know a priori just how much
external traffic each being gets I am
back to my warm-up case you can get a
straight line okay thank you
cool so one more question yes yes yes go
ahead so uh what are some Fair
allocation objectives that would be
interesting for this model
you can think of maximum
for example you can think of like
maximum over groups or like even like
you can think of individual Max mean if
I have like I don't know a bunch of
opportunities I want to maximize the
minimum feel rate of different
opportunities right so that could work
but you can also try to group them
somehow
real world
I think that volunteer match currently
is a very imbalanced Market in the sense
that we have many more opportunities
than volatives
because of this lots of opportunities
don't get any attention for long periods
of time
and that's not desirable
so after discussions lots of discussions
with volunteer match managers we decided
to focus on the goal of
redistributing the limited number of
weekly sign ups that we get
to as many opportunities as we can by
trying to prioritize those that are
currently not getting enough efficient
so toward achieving that goal we propose
a smart sort which is this real simple
algorithm
so this is how it works for every
opportunity I'm gonna have a counter
which keeps track of the number of sign
ups during the last week
I'm going back to Irene's earlier
question we can only update this on a
daily basis so we don't have real-time
updates
now each time a new volunteer shows up
we are going to uh
display to her a list an ordered list
that is ordered based on a new scoring
function
this Sigma I committee
a combination of our old scoring
function and a penalty function
so our old scoring function roughly
speaking is uh kind of tries to capture
preferences for uh closeness and recency
okay so an opportunity is going to have
a higher score if it is closer to this
particular volunteer or it has been
updated more recently
all right
and this penalty function is of course
plays the same role as it did in our
Theory work it's going to penalize or
deprioritize opportunities that received
some signs
let me show you a quick for example that
we use to convince volunteer match
managers
and go over the mechanics of this before
telling you very briefly about our
Pilots
so here's the two example
say I live in a world with only two
volunteers from the same location and
both of these two volunteers are only
going to pay attention to the top listed
opportunity
now say I also have two opportunities
and based on the old scoring function
these scores are such that opportunity
number one is ranked first
so this first volunteer is going to
assign is going to sign up for that
nothing changes in my scores so the
second volunteer is going to sign up for
that too this is going to lead to this
kind of skewed distribution which is
kind of the toy version of the real deal
I showed you at the beginning
so this is under the old scoring
function what happens on their hours
so for the first volunteer nothing same
thing is going to happen but now for the
second volunteer volunteer because this
opportunity already received the sign up
is going to be penalized I cooked up
these numbers such that it now has a
smaller score
so this other opportunity is going to be
shown first
this would lead to this kind of more
uniform silence
let me use Simple example and I want to
repeat the point that many previous
speakers make if you want to communicate
with practitioners this is the level of
simplicity at that units okay so we
literally showed examples of this level
uh to convince them that this idea of
adding this feedback loop can be very
helpful
the convincing them and working with
them for months we did Implement a smart
sort on volunteer match and we run a
pilot study in Dallas over summer
I experiment was 10 weeks long so the
post treatment is going to be 10 weeks
after May 24 and we're going to take the
pre-treatment to be the 10 weeks uh
prior to that okay
let me give you some basic statistics
just to just to get a sense of the scope
of our experiment
uh in this pre-treatment periods we had
about 20 000 visitors
is roughly about 0.6 percent of users
okay so Point uh six percent of users
were exposed to our treatment
and
these users again this is pre-treatment
period these visitors generated about
2100 signups and we had about 1100
active or newly created opportunities
and hopefully these last two points show
you how imbalanced this Market is okay
so many opportunities did not get uh any
sign ups during this effect
okay
good let me show you what our treatment
did
now we expect the effect of our
treatment to be heterogeneous right our
goal is redistribution so we know we're
going to treat different opportunities
differently
in particular those that do well we
expect them to uh kind of have a fewer
signups right they expect to have a
negative treatment effect because we are
deprioritizing them
in the hope that you're going to help a
bunch of other volunteers that were not
doing well before our treatments okay so
because of this heterogeneity in
treatment effect what we're gonna do is
that you're going to first partition our
opportunities into different groups
after doing this you're going to
basically conduct empirical analysis for
each group separately
what do we do
um first we're going to order our
opportunities based on the average
number of weekly sign ups they got
pre-treatment okay so this is basically
the performance pre-treatment
we partitioned them into beans of size
20.
you're going to take the data from
previous year
2021 same region same time period as our
control and we are going to construct
synthetic controls
by matching on pre-treatment Trends
because there's a lot of seasonality
so actually they rely on a nice a recent
AER paper by arkan gilski so long story
short after doing this analysis for each
pin separately this is what they get so
this is the average treatment effect or
the average difference in the number of
weekly sign ups for this array of
different beats
what do we see
on the left side for the opportunities
that they're kind of high performing
before our treatment before applying our
algorithm we see that post-treatment we
have negative uh effects right so they
got fewer sign ups but on the other side
for those that were not doing well
pre-treatment
now we helped them to get a few more
so this is kind of one sample of the
preliminary evidence they have for the
redistributive effect of our policy our
algorithm
thank you again very much still work in
progress
but looks quite promising
um just last week we launched a second
experiment a much larger one in Southern
California to fully understand the
effect of our policy and also fine-tunes
the parameters in in our in our
algorithm
but the hope is that sometime during
next year this is going to be rolled out
University
okay so stay tuned for more updates on
that but on next note uh thank you all
I'm happy to answer any further
questions
so we
so I understand that you see this effect
with respect to redistribution which on
some level should be expected right
because like you show those things more
but uh yeah do you actually see overall
that more opportunities are felt or like
in in some sense that is not the
objective function right good good good
yes we are not that's that's a great
question in terms of total number of
sign ups we are not impacting it much
okay so that's we we have that analysis
I didn't put it on the slides but we are
not impacting the total number of
signups uh by doing this
clearly if you keep showing a lot of
really
I don't know unpopular or bad
opportunities then maybe the total
number of sign up also goes down that's
why we want to be careful in terms of
like how we are doing this
prioritization
that's a great question
then
it's kind of a follow-up question to
Daniel's question like is
um the organization that you're working
with do they have like what is their
objective in using this redistribution
is there do they have a particular
organizational level goal that makes
that benefits them to
redistribute opportunities to more
organizations and is there a way to
measure that goal like Downstream good
good so great question so uh just to
make sure I understand the question your
question example is the objective of
volunteer match uh in uh in respect to
redistribution good good so they want to
help as many opportunities as possible
and they want to keep them engaged right
so if I if
and I don't get anything out of
volunteer match for six months or
something I'm Gonna Leave is like right
so that's why they like to keep their uh
their update they like to kind of help
all of their opportunities kind of on a
regular basis you they don't want to
leave someone out for a very long period
of time okay so that is the benefit of
your distribution on a kind of weekly
level right so we are not doing it for a
very long time Horizon to answer the
second part of the question one of the
measures we look at is a measure of
excess which is the fraction of total
synops
that go to opportunities
who get at least one right so think
about the distribution take out one kind
of a baseline for every operation for
every organization and then just compute
the fraction of the rest we call it
excess we actually showed through
regression analysis that we do decrease
excess meaning that we make the
distribution more uniform
thank you
um for these opportunities do they have
capacity constraints or demands for
example I can imagine some of them only
want one person and some of them want 10
people does that happen in this example
and if so how do you account for that
so does it happen in uh in by the
example you mean that I am incorporating
it in my
at design
I mean I mean like
um on the volunteer match platform do
the the opportunities is it sort of like
one opportunity corresponds to one
person who wanted or can they have
demand for multiple people in the same
opportunity good good yes yes they do
give a number of requested volunteers so
for example this opportunity needs five
balances the other one that needs two
volunteers and so so yes we do have that
information
at the moment you're just trying to give
everyone at least one on a weekly basis
right
first order
um is there like a notion of preserving
the overall the long-term health of the
platform in terms of maybe the high
demand opportunities are just uh better
run and better organized and so we're
okay with them getting Surplus sign up
uh for the long-term Health good good
for the long-term Health actually you
don't want to do that for the following
reason they're not going to reach back
to the excess volunteers those
volunteers never hear back they get
disengaged and you end up with a
platform with less number of volunteers
and at the moment I remind you this is a
this is a market in which volunteers are
very much on the short side so you don't
want to lose anyone okay that's it good
question for like a different Market
um so if you wanted to optimize for a
sort of min max objective like uh you
know I want to fill uh every need to a
certain fraction and I want to maximize
the the minimum fraction I'm filling uh
is that is there something known for
that uh for online matching that's a
great question the thing is that balance
by the virtual kind of minimizing risk
uh by kind of balancing the fill rate it
sort of automatically achieves that
right okay
so Iranian algorithm achievement the the
basic online matching algorithm so like
that's called msdv or our version both
of them they try to keep field rates
relatively equally modular debates like
I'm putting weights aside that's why
they kind of automatically are balanced
they they try to kind of be fair but
that's not their objective right I see
so is that uh I mean can you prove that
as a theorem uh like is that so if if
that were my objective would this
algorithm be uh brisk is optimal I not
so here's the thing when I have
adversarial model min max is a very
sensitive objective function I I bet you
can cook up examples that you get
nothing but for stochastic models I
think Will has a paper on this right so
there has been results on for the
stochastic arable okay got it
so this is primarily about sign ups
right does volunteer match have any
issues with folks signing up but not
showing up for the actual event oh
that's great yeah yeah if so are there
systematic differences between the
likelihood of someone to do that given
that they're an internal or an external
sign up or between the opportunities
that's an excellent question think of
this as a very young organization you
still don't have information on those
kind of second stage
phases but so they try to just create as
many signups as possible they don't have
visibility to kind of the next stage but
definitely they want to do that in the
future
uh yeah last question and then we'll
move to the next session
is this even feasible based on they like
uh will they have can they have access
to the information about who showed up
to the opportunity or not not
good they can like add
update hey did this person show up for
your uh opportunity or not but nothing
directly for sure
items
okay let's thank again
[Applause]
so now uh to wrap up the work